president Trump unleashing on Democrats
and pummeling Joe Biden during a fiery
campaign rally it was his first since
the Democrats launched their inquiry the
president wasted no time going on the
attack
Democrats are on a crusade to destroy
our democracy that's what's happening
the wretched Washington swamp has been
trying to nullify the results of a truly
great and democratic election they want
to erase your vote like it never existed
they want to erase your voice and they
want to erase your future so they know
they can't win the 2020 election so
they're pursuing the insane impeachment
witch hunt Trump also honing in on Joe
Biden and his son hunter making their
shady ukraine' dealings a top campaign
target where's hunter hey fellas I have
an idea for a new t-shirt
I love the cups but let's do another
t-shirt where's hunter where's hunter
you're a loser why did you get one point
five billion dollars hunter and your
father was never considered smart he was
never considered a good senator he was
only a good vice president because he
understood how to kiss Barack Obama's
ass the Biden's got rich and that is
substantiated while America got robbed
that's what happened
sleepy Joe and his friends sold out
American
wow it's a tough line of attack one
Biden's got rich America got robbed and
by the way where is hunter
I mean I say I'm just so heartbroken for
America that that's the president that's
the way he talks and that's the way he
talks about people who are his political
rivals I mean it's not a I mean we could
do the journalistic thing and save so
much of this has trumped unsubstantiated
charges and you know he just wants to
throw dirt at somebody but it's just
heartbreaking
that that's the President of the United
States in front of our kids talking
about the former vice president whether
you like him or not I don't want to
repeat what he just said I mean that you
know he had his lips adhere to some I
mean it's just it's just unbelievable
it's not you know at some point but with
Trump you say Oh Trump is so
entertaining you know Trump is gonna be
funny or it's like a schoolyard kid but
in that moment all right and the second
point Jesse I think it's pretty clear
from that attack last night that there's
only one Democrat that he is concerned
with and that's Joe Biden he doesn't
attack Elizabeth Warren who's been doing
well in the polls he doesn't attack
Bernie Sanders who does well in the
polls both have done better than Biden
in terms of fundraising over the last
quarter but his actions and his words
everything from Ukraine and those
unsubstantiated theories to this show
that he is really worried about Joe
Biden and this week in the Fox polls
what other polls as well show Biden
beating him handily and of course this
week we also had Rudy Giuliani's pals
going to Ukraine or being paid by Julian
or somebody to try to influence American
politics to get that ambassador thrown
out who testified today but again they
were going after dirt on Joe Biden when
Joe Biden and his son had been found to
be guilty of zero okay one very dark and
gloomy analysis Greg let's go to you for
a little bit more spunk I surprised I
don't feel the same way Wanda I find it
interesting when people are shocked by
Donald Trump it's three years okay
that's a trump rally you got to get over
it
I mean you're like the guy that opens up
the fridge knows that the milk is sour
and you still sniff it and you're oh my
god the milk is sour
that's Trump is he and by the way you
act like this is like this is somehow
new in general this is how the left how
Democrats have talked about people
privately have demeaned us how academia
entertainment have talked about America
this guy is just taken the what's inside
and taking it outside so in there's
somebody smarter than me you know they
look at this and they go oh my god
that the new line is this isn't normal
well you're right it isn't normal
that's why he won because that's not the
typical politician you can hate him you
can hate him every single day it's not
gonna change and by the way you got to
look at the energy of that rally and you
got to wonder if the Democrats are
really thinking straight about this
impeachment because what the left always
wanted they always wanted a
revolutionary their American version of
Fidel their American version of Che they
always wanted that in a real weird way
they thought Obama would be that how
hilarious is it that the revolutionary
is a Republican talk show host right
their impeachment is going to turn Trump
into a revolutionary to a lot of people
in a positive way that will create a
movement so they got to understand that
this is actually going to help Trump
when you see the energy that he has and
then you compare it to Biden at the town
hall on CNN here you have Trump talking
clearly saying exactly what he's
thinking and you see Biden sounding like
he's reading from a Reader's Digest
magazine five years ago that he found on
the train yeah a lot of energy a lot of
charisma last night he went after Paige
and struck and a pretty interesting for
right let's listen to that and Katie can
react beat is struck
remember he and his lover Lisa Paige I
love you Peter I love you too Lisa at
least hello Lisa
Lisa oh god I love you Lisa and if she
doesn't win Lisa we've got it insurance
policy Lisa oh man a lot of targets out
there holy accurate description of text
messages between men wait did he
dramatize them like Lisa Paige actually
ended up testing fiying against Peter
struck and kind of blowing up his story
that he told to Congress under oath but
in terms of the president and his
demeanor and his attitude one thing he
has on Democrats is that he's completely
secure with who he is he doesn't care
what he says Democrats on the other hand
have had a very hard time finding their
own platforms whether it's Joe Biden or
Kamala Harris they have a difficult time
defending their positions which is
Elizabeth Warren has changed hers so
many times and so when it comes to
getting on the campaign trail with one
person of course Trump is going after
Joe Biden because he still is the
front-runner he wants to knock him out
to get to Elizabeth Warren because the
country sees her as too far left and so
the energy that he has in a place like
Minnesota which is a generally blue
state with 22,000 plus people waiting in
line is going to be very difficult for
Democrats to compete with in states they
don't want to be defending without the
amount of cash on hand as a Trump
campaign yeah they got a lot of data
last night from that huge crowd and
they're gonna harvest that and you know
fundraise and turn them out they have a
much better chance of flipping Minnesota
than other states that they've talked
about like Nevada although New Hampshire
I think is still in their sights New
Mexico I think probably out of reach but
then they might think differently and
they do everywhere they go they get all
of this data and some coverage says that
this was off script like nope this is
the Sarita and you know my feelings on
that's pretty clear like I don't think
it's necessary to call somebody's son a
loser you can question whether they were
peddling influence and whether that was
inappropriate and I think that's
actually a pretty strong argument and
the Biden's are actually complaining
that the DNC isn't defending them enough
the DNC is like you like you want to be
able to defend yourself mm-hm and
they've known that this is coming for a
long time and they aren't able to get
off their back foot however
even with all of this in the last three
weeks Biden is still doing pretty well
across the board so he has staying power
and maybe one of these things like when
people say it doesn't matter when it
comes to Trump well maybe it doesn't
matter when it comes to Biden yeah I
mean there is if there is something I
hate to use the phrase baked into the
cake because I hate that phrase but with
Trump his his personality is baked into
the cake and Biden's foibles are all
everybody like everybody knows what's
wrong with Biden but they might just
have to bite the bullet on that one yeah
because they don't have anybody else
know because I don't think there's any
question that the left is unified on the
point of defeating Donald Trump right
and also getting rid by no I don't think
that's true Danis point is well-taken
that you know the kind of narrative
point has been for the way ever Oh
Warren's gaining Biden's fading right
but in fact if you look at the numbers
they indicate that her gains are not
coming from Biden Biden remains on top
yeah but if you take Bernie Sanders out
of the polling and you add his far left
voters to Elizabeth Warren they're not a
little bit all going to vote for her but
it's actually leapfrogs over Joe Biden's
numbers and you have to question why the
dividing campaign continues to say we
don't have to win Iowa we don't have to
win New Hampshire well maybe we're not
gonna try in those states and there's
this question to if Joe Biden keeps
lashing out at the media well what
where's the double standard on that you
know Trump says stuff about the media
and he's accused of all these things but
Joe Biden sending mean letters the New
York Times and telling us about
questions about his family and and maybe
questions about the campaign you say
that but it's a big difference no he
didn't we said you didn't like Peter
Schweitzer who has obviously you know
been involved in making allegations
sometimes sanchita complaining about
media coverage one not a good thing no
but to pay as the American press cuz the
enemy of the people that from the big
business all right